so so far yeah with all the craziness
you saw by the way
what's her name uh uh camille uh vasquez
yeah has officially become a bm bmf
people are in love with this girl 38
year old lawyer what i want to know is
how the hell did he find her like what
did that show up that was apparently a
very deliberate
choice because they said that the two
lawyers are the big guys they're guys
your size apparently look at it and if
you had a big man
asking these these very hard questions
to a beautiful woman who's crying you
would look like a bully
let's get a very smart small
sarcastic no i'm being serious what a
strategic let's get a very small people
who came up with
the team when you're johnny depp and you
get that team
i promise you they're the best yeah i
know some of these people you know that
in hollywood who deal with this they're
the guys that make it to the top those
lawyers they they are deep deep students
of hum of of human nature so here's my
question though
how did because dude not everybody's
definition i know it's them but do they
have to agree and like it's going to be
televised and it's going to be on every
single day like what what makes that
look this this case rests on on the
first half of that the sentence the
first sentence of that of that article
yeah i was i was i became the face of
domestic violence the idea was you wrote
that and then you orchestrated
um your follow-up plan to essentially
destroy someone's career and the case
really is the lawyer's case is
we're going to prove that everything you
said is not true
right you're making this stuff up we
don't have there's no pattern of this in
his in his history or anything else all
of a sudden you came along said that i
mean if you listen to those tapes
it's like she's saying i'm i can't help
but i get so mad i can't promise i won't
hit you
yeah i wasn't hitting you johnny i don't
know what my hand i didn't punch you i
was hitting oh that's a big difference
so all of us just go i'm sorry but mo
there's people like why is that why does
the internet hate amber heard well
most of us the people who don't have a
dog in this race
are like i dude i just don't buy it i
don't believe you i don't believe you
the letter that you're referring to she
wrote that she was the face of domestic
violence
she wrote an article for the washington
post or the
that that basically said
um
if you look at the first
sentence i think it was really about
whether or not she was
did this was a defamation thing i spoke
up against sexual violence face i faced
our culture as wrath that that has to
change
and then i was exposed to abuse at a
very young age blah blah blah blah
there's a there's a sentence that
they're using that that
now you have to prove whether or not
everything she's saying is a lie
let me ask you a question then oh yeah
there it is two years ago i became a
public figure representing domestic
abuse and i felt the full force of our i
became a public figure representing
domestic abuse that's where i believe
it's hinging on you said that you were
abused and then you filed a restraining
order and and i i will say this if you
rest if you file a restraining order in
los angeles you don't need to go down
there personally with your with your um
uh publicist you don't if you file for
divorce you don't have to go down there
personally you don't do that a lawyer
does that for you a clerk does that for
you
so why was she down there you know
without makeup on that cheek there was
and also if you heard the tmz guy he
goes well
we have to vet who has the copyright for
any video we get
and that'll take up to a day or a week
in this case it took 15 minutes because
it came from quote unquote the source
that was her well it came directly from
her i saw i mean that's what i mean come
on
if it took 15 minutes
tmz was like oh well brian and if you
were supposed to believe all women well
yeah except for uh just lane maxwell
the woman from fairness i was just gonna
say
how are you processing this believe all
women how are your categories i have a
big problem with any of that so any
blanket statement that this can i say
one thing though look at what americans
love this type of like this trial
where's jelaine maxwell what happened to
that whole i would rather see that trial
than watch this i hate to be that guy
where's she at now where when the last
time you heard of elaine maxwell yeah no
no i know where she is she the depp was
the one
who wanted the cameras in the courtroom
oh really
she didn't and he knew these this is
by the way look man that guy's a
nightmare too okay i i don't think he
was i don't think he hit her didn't but
that guy spent 30 years high
high and drunk off his ass
nightmare he was jack sparrow in real
life dressed like a pirate all the time
look if i came in bro with a lace doily
around my head a cowboy hat and 15
bandanas you'd go brian
i take it off right now
i know bro but you gotta have friends
who are like hey dude you're you're
dressed like you're 13 bracelets but
that's what johnny depp is you're 60.
just because he's captain jack sparrow
drinking rum on on a cruise on a
doesn't mean that he's beaten women in
acting class i took it for years in
acting you learn the most important
thing which is what
learn how to be still yeah
learn to give nothing away let the
audience i never learned this by the way
not even close to the worst student let
the audience reach for you brando brown
was the first guy who just steve
mumble's words
back then you always had to enunciate
you learned how to stand straight and
you and you spoke this way you were an
actor that was very important yeah
brandon came along when he walked on
stage in in
in london
he came on stage
and he was talking like you stanley
kowalski when he was doing street car
names there
in london they thought a drunk stagehand
had walked on stage
they were like
what's going on oh my god somebody's
storming the stage then they realized he
was in it they saw his muscles and they
saw he was actually sweating for real
because he used to work out the first
method actor
in london
they were cheered the story goes they
were screaming the women were screaming
at when at that curtain called screaming
he changed all of it
robert de niro robert duvall all those
guys you know who their hero was brandon
of course brando so you know the the
depp is a master actor dude he seduced
all of us by barely moving it takes him
a half hour to get one sentence out one
one sentence he's like i uh
it was
no
what that's all he says we're like dude
i need to hear more yeah i love it is it
true you had a you had a pint of wine
a mega bind a mega pipe i had a large
glass of wine i felt very necessary but
who's your favorite uh
yes you continue to read that correctly
he barely raises his voice how much was
he spending on wine he even admitted it
30 grand a month a month that's as much
as patrick david does so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]